the Trump thing was just taking it to
the next level but it's kind of funny in
our building
there are three couples that love Trump
to Orthodox Jewish couples and another
some kind of Gentile couple they love
Trump I mean I think there's a lot of
people in New York who who like him or
love him but they just don't say it
publicly you know I don't I don't wear
mag a hat down Madison Avenue you do you
live in New York City right now I live
in Manhattan I'm here now and yeah I
live in Manhattan the reason I ask is
because to espouse those radical views
that you've just announced in Manhattan
in a strange time to live in Manhattan I
assume you have two locks on your door
well you know in all seriousness Dave if
you think about it you know being a
born-again evangelicals and I'm not
exactly a popular way to fly around here
and I've always been before Trump I
believed in the in the dignity of the
unborn I take that very seriously I have
a biblical view of sexuality you know
these are not like popular views in blue
states but the point is that this is
where I'm from I try to be respectful of
people with with whom I differ
I don't lose friendships over those
things I love people with whom I
disagree on these things and so so the
Trump thing with just taking it to the
next level but it's kind of funny in our
building there are three couples that
love Trump to Orthodox Jewish couples
and another some kind of Gentile couple
they love Trump I mean I think there's a
lot of people in New York who who like
him or love him but they just don't say
it publicly you know I don't I don't
where Magga hat down Madison Avenue yeah
as we're going through we're taping this
a little bit before we're gonna air it
so I don't want to get into like the
exact nitty-gritty of what's happening
but as we're going as we're going
through this sort of national tumult and
all of this stuff and sort of the
unraveling of the the fabric of America
you sort of described before as your
your Greek father and your German mother
and all of that and as a guy that lives
in New York City and you just mentioned
some of the people in your building are
you worried that we're gonna look back
and go man we had something that was so
freaking precious and we didn't even
realize it that perhaps the ship has
even sailed on that already I am funny
you should bring that up because I've
thought about this day and night for
four years now I wrote a book I don't
have a copy here but if I could give a
copy to everyone in your audience
everyone in America it's called if you
can keep it Franklin was asked after the
Constitutional Convention
you know dr. Frank we're gonna get to it
let's do it right now well that that's
we'll link to it will link to it yeah
but but but the fact of the matter is
that over the years because of my faith
and because of my choose me evolving
political views I began to notice some
things right and I began to notice for
example one of the reasons America is
great is that it's an idea it's not an
ethnic tribal group right everybody my
father with his Greek accent my mother
with a German accent
they can become as American as George
Washington that's a new concept in the
history of the world it's a beautiful
concept and so if it's true that America
is an idea
and if we're self-governing unless
people know that idea understand how
that works and live out that idea of
governing themselves and in a sense
teaching others how to self-govern what
this means how fragile and beautiful
this is and what we must do to keep it
if we don't it goes away absolutely
there's just no question if there's no
question whether it will go away it will
go away it's been going away so I wrote
my book if you can keep it specifically
to put in in a small easily readable
book the very basics of what one needs
to know to get it why you need to love
your country with all its flaws why you
must love your country why you must
fight for liberty and on and on and on
and I have to say in large part because
I am a Christian I have
hope when most people wouldn't see hope
I I think God's had his hand on this
country
listen Lincoln called us the almost
chosen people now why would he say that
he said it because he knew he could see
that there was something in fact he used
the phrase something uncommon this is
not just another country if you believe
that God has had his hand on the Jews
which I certainly do that's not
something you party about right it's
it's a it's a tremendous burden to be
chosen by God because it means he's
going to use you and you're going to
suffer and it's not going to be easy and
and so God has blessed this country
amazingly but he's used this country to
export liberty and wealth and on and on
to the whole world because you know just
as Israel was created by God to reach
the whole world to reach the nations
outside of Israel America and all our
blessings are intended for the rest of
the world so we have something that is
so precious and when I really understood
this I I wrote the book and I I have
been on a mission because I said if we
don't educate the next generation or
even this generation it does go away and
what we're seeing right now I think is
the it's the it's the the the heat of
the battle we're in the midst of a
battle where we have a president in a
sense who by God's grace has dragged us
back from the cliff of oblivion and so
we have some time you know
to back away from the cliff but if
Hillary had been elected which is you
know you asked me earlier why why how
could I vote for Trump I'm convinced
that that Hillary Clinton and Obama and
those folks are genuinely tremendously
corrupt in other words that they will
put their own interests before the
interests of the country so that's
strike three but I also believe that
their version of America their view of
America is fundamentally antithetical to
the founders view the founders view of
America they don't share they want to
undo it they have worked cleverly over
the decades to undo it along with all
the institutions I mentioned earlier and
I really believe that
had Hillary been elected for example and
instead of Robertson Cavanaugh we had
gotten you know son of Sotomayor and
bride of Sotomayor if that had happened
it's over the Constitution just because
it's a piece of paper it's meaningless
unless we have judges that are
interpreting things according to it
unless we have people that understand it
so to me there's no question that we're
we're right on that precipice as it were
yeah so I suspect you think that even
some of the Republicans who you said
before you might have liked or at one
time supported or something like that
you think they wouldn't have been able
to stand up against this thing either
right oh they weren't standing up
against it they weren't look these are
people that I like but they were not
standing up against it that it takes
tremendous courage to stand up against
what we now call the deep state the deep
state is as tyrannical as King George
the third was it is the enemy of
self-government and liberty and when I
talk about Liberty I'm not talking about
some french idea of Liberty I'm talking
about God's idea of Liberty and how
human beings are supposed to live and
and if you don't go to war with that if
you play pattycake with that because you
think well I don't want to be the one
you know the press already hates me
eventually it's going to get worse and
worse and worse and so I really think
that unfortunately I can't you know
understand how else it could have
happened but we have had leaders who've
been guilty of what people have said to
me over the years but I never believed
it that they're they're really no
different than the other side and I
thought to myself you know that's truer
than I would like to believe when when
McCain voted against you know
overturning Obamacare I thought what a
what a nightmare what a nightmare that a
man who was tortured for his country has
come to this exceedingly peevish sick
moment in his life just before he dies
that he would do something like that
that's the guy that I voted for Mitt
Romney similarly I voted for the fact
that he would take what he pretends as a
principled stand against this president
I think I would like to think that these
folks are deluded
that that their their evil actions are
the result of really being diluted
because otherwise it's it's too
disturbing so we talked a little bit
about this when you interviewed me but I
thought this might be a nice way to sort
of to bring this all full circle but you
don't strike me as like a purely
political beast in that you care about
things that are sort of much bigger than
politics so it you know politics is just
a piece of it but yet these days
everything has become so political and
I'm wondering what else do you think is
important to live a full clear life well
there's no question that my faith in the
God of the Bible is the most important
thing and that it's efuses
or at least I hope it suffuses every
part of me and takes precedence over
every part of me or every other part of
me I think that you know people who
think you can solve things through
politics are just wrong if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell